Tracer fire streaks across the skyline
then
a direct hit intercepting an incoming
missile Russia has gone on the attack
ahead of Ukraine's counter-offensive
if you believe the country would last a
month against Russia now this Army of
underdogs is gearing up for a battle
that could choose pivotal in the course
of the war
training at a quarry 15 miles from the
front line their instructor Spartacus
has been fighting the Russians since
2014. so what kind of weapons are you
training these Soldiers with uh we got a
Soviet weapon and American Weapon It's
American grenades M65 baseball frag
it's a 40 millimeter grenades Tracer
fire streaks across the skyline then
a direct hit intercepting an incoming
missile Russia has gone on the